this is a production of Cornell
University
well well it is really a big honor for
me to be given an opportunity to visit
Cornell of course Cornell we give this
University high regard in the
Philippines especially there in our
universe
and share to you what we have been doing
in the Philippines
and uh I was also thankful to Dr Matson
because
of being patient and how we can get
through this scholarship this Fellowship
during the government
and now that I'm here I'm so glad to
meet his team at the kpl
and meet everyone and of course share to
you today what we have in the
Philippines
well we have been involved in the
promotion of urban agriculture in the
Philippines particularly the technology
of Hydroponics and aquaponics and
greenhouses or benefit culture and uh
a controlled environment control
agriculture environment then you know in
the Philippines investment and funding
is the very big project
but we try to
do whatever we have there locally
available materials just to have this
so to start with I want to
first talk about myself
I was born in this little island in the
Philippines
they called
it has six uh towns and it is situated
in the central part of the Philippines
I spent my childhood there actually my
childhood is not is we are the
struggling Covenant farming families but
we thank our parents that we they taught
us how to
go through with our lives
and I spent my Elementary and high
school in this place I was given an
opportunity to
go through central Arizona State
University to take a Bachelor of Science
in agricultural engineering where I
graduated in 1983
and my study is all about Rice School
Dance
I also took up master of science in
agricultural engineering
when I graduated in 1989 focusing on the
automation of pressurized segregation
systems
using soil moisture then I pursued my
PhD in agricultural engineering
completing it by 2008 focusing on Water
Management systems for hydroponic
coniture balance
later I was sent to a University of
Arizona in Tucson
and I completed a six-month scholarship
program under Fulbright
but in 2012 and my study is all about
the integration of freshwater abroad
in aquaponic systems for tilapia lettuce
peptoy and cabbage culture
and right now I am here at Cornell with
this Advanced research and University
lecturing program under Fulbright
and I am focusing on the study of on the
effect of pH on the grown and real and
quality and cannot denied content
with drapas
after graduation I went to the Middle
East for six years I became an
agricultural engineer Landscaping
engineer verification engineer doing
everything there in the desert
uh we are installing and maintaining
grip navigation systems spring builders
in greenhouses and open field for the
hours
and I was also involved in the
establishment of modern farms and water
management for pressure rest irrigation
systems in the sultanate of Oman where
the sultan had given lands to the omanis
so we our company participated a lot in
those programs
when I uh settled for in the Philippines
for good I started us
a substitute teacher High School teacher
at centralism State University
and
I participate until I become
a professor at the department of
agricultural devices service engineering
technology engineering in that
University
I did uh Agricultural and biosystems
Engineering subjects and one of the
subjects that I love is all about
Advanced Techniques to from culture
which focuses on the things that I love
to do all about Hydroponics aquaponics
and
uh control agriculture environment
so later that uh when we called it hit
the Philippines
the secretary of agriculture called some
of the uh uh researchers in Philippine
universities and I was one of those and
I was uh instructed to lead the urban
farming Innovation Center
we're in we are promoting Urban
agriculture with innovate the Innovative
Technologies and we established
demonstration Farms especially in Metro
Manila and other big cities in the
Philippines we also assist and provide
suggestions in the policy making and
implementation of urban agriculture in
the country
so central Arizona State University is
located there
in the central part of Luzon
so it is about
150 about uh four hours drive from Metro
Manila the capital city
so the early developments in clsu is
when I have this design of automatic
communication controllers for Dockers
using local soil moisture activated
controller
and uh I believe that
a great idea as it started from crew
uh idea
and we started from this so we employ
this in our studies and research in uh
the board chart of the universe
later I was called by our
our University to lead the establishment
of a demonstration Farm using the
Israeli greenhouses and Technologies uh
for the production of honeydew melon and
we do that in the soil we are not we are
doing that in soil in soilist culture
but we were able to produce uh
uh superior quality of honey
and they love it
later I pursued my PhD and I focused on
the hydroponic honey to melon on Water
Management of uh hydropology melon and
this is my study as you can see in the
pictures
we do not have such uh systems that you
have here so we have to invent
of our own system using the locally
available materials like that
and later I was sent by Fulbright to
University of Arizona wherein I have
this integration abroad with tilapia and
vegetablesystems
and uh it is actually the result of this
is available online published under the
uh scholarship uh Publishing House in
German
and here you can see my faculty
professor
Dr Kevin Fitzsimmons
and and
uh all those prawns that we have grown
in this system the problem is uh located
situated under the the uh rough system
not with the tilapia
so in one of the University of Arizona I
uh also involved myself in the
production of tomatoes mushrooms and
controlled environment and the culture
and I got a lot of knowledge about what
they are doing there in Biosphere 2 and
in the lunar Greenhouse so uh I attended
lectures on how they do this which
probably I can use in when I go back to
the Philippines now this is my report
this is what I'm going to share
so
there are many Publications that tells
that scientists all over the world agree
that today's agricultural production
systems are not any more suitable for
the Newport security challenges of our
century
that is prevailing farming systems
cannot meet the food requirements of a
growing population
in the first uh tier in this diagram you
can see an area in Orange
uh bounded by the red and green
and since 2010 to 2050
that area is increasing that means that
the food requirement of the population
is increasing and probably according to
scientists by 2030 which is seven years
from now in many parts of the world
there will be severe hunger
which would result to chaos
and that would threaten the peace on our
uh in the globe in the Philippines
despite the advances that we have in
modern agriculture that is from Farm
mechanization that the government is
pursuing to protected cultivation onto
plant genetics food production
especially in our country remains at the
mercy of the changing climate subject to
various destructive elements of natural
and man-made disasters
and there are other serious interrelated
problems like overpopulation Urban
migration and the Aging farmers
and of course
corruption because we are popular with
corruption
So based on the United Nations product
projection as of today we will have a
population of 117 million
more than that
and it is scattered in only three
hundred thousand square kilometers
if you are going to study that that is
six times greater than the population of
New York
actually we are ranking about 1.4 we
have we have one we are one point four
to six percent of the total world
population ranking number 13 in the
world
not a small touch
and the population density is about 384
people per square kilometers in Metro
Manila alone those that that colored
area there propose of several small
cities
but we have we are the most the fourth
world's most crowded City
and talking of this of Manila
this one
it is
the most densely populated city in the
world
well this is one of the big problems
that we have in students
and also because of this people want to
to go to the cities
the countryside they do not want to be
farmers
in 2015 it is about 51.2 percent
the rural population is about
48.8 percent
by 2020 it had increased to 54 percent
so living the old farmers in the local
communities
to work on the parks
and the average age of Filipino Farmers
now is between 57 to
60 just imagine
that age you'll be working in the
department
so there will be a critical shortage of
Farm Workers within 15 years and
actually it's happening now
and
our youth love to stay in
the city
Dominique computers they love they don't
want to kill the soil
and also the impact of climate change in
our country
the Philippine agriculture is sick we
have accepted that and dying
its contribution to the country's GDP
has dropped and continues to decline
over the years
vegetable industry alone is almost in
comatose condition because every year we
are devastated by so many natural
disasters especially typhoons
and Farmers Financial condition
continues to worsen their dignity
crossed and devastated that is why
farmers found farming not profitable
anymore
and as an attractive business so they
were forced to sell their lands to
business
just lately we I a big thankful
destructive typo there's a bus to the
Philippines and
the regions in the northern part of the
Philippines were Dynasty rice for
example
that's why we are I'm not going to call
Toronto agricultural country but we are
one of the
uh highest ranking importer of Rights
because we are rice eating country
so because of this when I arrived from
Tucson from Arizona
I thought it is much uh it is not proper
for me to to utilize what we have
learned so I submitted proposals to the
government particularly in the
department of Science and Technology and
I was awarded of six uh projects from
2012 to 2022 and we were able to develop
this uh demo Farm
and from this demo farm that has become
a center of of a promotion of modern
technology into Philippines of course
what we have there is not similar to
your high-tech gear technology but
this is a proof that we Filipino can do
it even in our own small way using
locally available materials and our
engineers
we were able to produce some
researches and result of this and one of
them is about uh Tomatoes we grow beef
steak and
uh cherry tomatoes
and the technology has been shared to
many people especially those in
commercial level
this uh sample this setup is scalable
and we can even improve this because
this is our prototype
from using our locally available
materials especially nutrient solution
which has become the biggest problem in
the hydroponic industry in the
Philippines
so we uh try to produce our own
hydroponic system we formulate our own
and share this to the government and
have it available at low price
so these systems that we have are
scalable from commercial to Backyard
this is our backyard systems so we can
grow here uh leafy vegetables and birds
and probably you will see how these
plants can grow in this system
because of the sunrise will not be
available to all all the levels but you
know we first harvest on the top
and every Harvest we promote everyone
and we start from the bottom again
so that's how we do that
some uh some uh it would include labors
but you know just to maximize the space
and the investment
and it was uh there will be a smaller
version of this we call household model
so it's smaller but it depends you know
because the capacity of our investors is
limited
and also we have this one square meter
Garden
which can be established in Condominiums
and small areas Even in our roof tanks
and also we use this for us a system for
aquaponics is one square meter plan
we also use the discarded fruit boxes
to contain nutrient solution and plug
their
lattices like this
and this is our system that we use for
tomato production
and somehow we were able to do some
research about this of course we can
improve this and this we always tell to
our Farmers to our investors that
there's a lot of things that needs to be
improved but we can start on what we
have learned
we also grew uh cucumbers
different types of cucumbers and we have
done some Harvest
what uh is good here is that we are not
only producing more
but we are producing safer
cleaner and fresher vegetables
so the nutrient solution that were
discarded are not prone to waste we use
that to fertilize our open programs like
dragon fruit
our dragon fruit is so sweet because we
you're delighted discarded fertilizer
from our Hydroponics systems
foreign
copies from grown in global culture
using aquaponics systems
and also some researchers conducted an
aquaponics systems for insulin plant
production
our University is introducing this
herbal medicine
so I
told them that there is a safer way to
do this and one of this is to do that
aquaponically rather than planting
inside
we also uh
Dr you know we constructed a
vertical interferment system there we
fabricated this out of our locally
available materials and we grow these
tomatoes and other leafy vegetables and
herbs we also try to grow uh
struggle
now when the coffee is 19 pandemic
happened
the agricultural agriculture agriculture
in the Philippines really suffered and
this pandemic have revealed the
fragility of Our Food Systems laptops
and checkpoints made food distribution
and delivery difficult to Impossible
in uh for some time maybe one month or
some weeks our country was paralyzed
because we do not know what to do
and many of our countrymen suffered
from hunger and poverty because no one
is allowed to book
our health and livelihood and of course
the economy was greatly devastated
this is what happened in the Philippines
before
we have so much production in the
countryside that should be brought to
the cities
but there is no government
delivery is prohibited
and also that's why most of the produce
are just from
sometimes spread to Lifestyle
so because of this the Philippine
government uh somehow give
assistance to our people
but there are also those uh agencies
private agencies and organizations who
help the communities which we call the
bayanihan we call this Pioneer
cooperation
it is a spirit
that was released during the pandemic
which is uh all about the community
community pantries and donations from
people
which somehow relieve our problems
during those times
so one of the government intervention is
to produce more vegetables produce more
food and so when the new secretary came
in the person of Dr William Darr we made
this a proposal plant plant and this is
all about Urban agriculture because the
urban areas was totally devastated
during those times and it encouraged the
Filipino to go back to farming
and to maximize the use and productivity
of every land resources and space
he is encouraging us to have a new
thinking for agriculture and that is to
apply modern technology
later a house bill was approved that
talks about the integrated Urban
agriculture Act
and that is all about the creation of
the urban
Agriculture and that leads to the
creation of the center which we call the
urban farming Innovation and learning
center
I was called to lead this program to
lead the center and we have done a lot
of campaign all over the country
and we have these uh Five Point agenda
just to unify and harmonize the
activities of the Department of
Agriculture and it called the people to
be involved in food production
and this is one of our setups that we
are introducing this is an aquaponics
system
and
we grew uh tilapia
this is our favorite and we grow a lot
of letters in disease
of course this is just a small uh maybe
this is just four by six square meters
but we we can scale this one
according to the uh Financial capability
of partner
also we try to
uh involve the uh
people are the urban dwellers to be
involved so all those people that are
living in urban areas we encourage them
to produce it and use all these spaces
even in their workspace
those people involved in tourism we help
them
so that all those who will uh have
vacation in their area will not only
enjoy the scenery that they have there
but we also learn how to do a school
and all those people in the in the
academic we try to introduce using their
roof deck for their universities
and one of them introduced this crops in
the sky or crops in the rooftop like
that
utilizing all the spaces in this city
and this one is one of our our
participants
doesn't have a space in their in their
area
so we use the Rooftop
and the production is really very uh
improved very much improved and they
love it and once they the neighborhood
learn about this one they were all
encouraged to do the same
so this is some of our uh projects
we involve we only use PBC pipes because
we do not have that rectangular one
at the end
and so somehow we we produce these
different types of vegetables
also
some of our clients
try to duplicate what we have there in
our research area and they put uh he
wants to try this for uh controlled
environment
using this fabricated uh chamber
so
if the Philippines actually
need help and that is why I told Dr
Manson
that if somehow we can have some
collaboration with our universities
because the Target now is the use
all those people in the academy must
call those students to learn more about
food production
and it must be included in their
curriculum
and so if we could have collaboration
and share
what you have here in Cornell
probably
it would be a great help to our people
and in conclusion Urban farming actually
we have found out is a valuable strategy
augmenting the code requirements in
urban and rural areas and utilizing
modern agriculture like smart and
presidential agriculture could enhance
food production that would utilize the
limited resources like water space and
energy
and policy makers should legislate laws
to involve the youth
because they will be the one who will
suffer if they will not in the religion
telling them that food security is not
only the concern of the government of
the the professors
but it is our concern all of us is
concerned
so we are encouraged to plant
plants no established
as a challenge our secretary is always
telling these ones
that no pandemic can vary our dreams and
aspirations
that no lockdowns can slow us down
so let us turn challenges into
opportunities to survive
and move forward towards a good secure
and resilient Philippines with
prosperous farmers and Fishers
and so we were all encouraged and
somehow
the Filipino people
were uh have have no new thinking for
agriculture because of his presence
before US Secretary
and from here I would like to thank you
very much for listening
wait sometimes
sometimes you know I have one questions
yes sir
um I'm gonna start I should just give
you one from a participation
participation perspective
how much participation are you seeing
recently from the through
uh growth in American culture the
participation of our group sir of the
general population oh okay people in the
city I mean how quickly is this growing
and where is it going oh before when we
introduced this uh Hydroponics and
aquaponics people are telling that this
is a stupid technology especially for a
country like the Philippines we're in we
are totally agricultural country
but later
you know just informing them the
importance of this and the relevance of
the benefits of this later after 10
years many have participated not only in
in the urban communities but also in uh
rural areas
and I would suggest from
a year one that we started this
we are probably about six from one to
ten we are about on level six of
acceptance and interest
and somehow
with the program that government I think
we have uh helped them it's not it not a
bunch of crazy scientists anymore so
they're accepting of it
how how is it going from there from
there uh our government is pursuing this
Urban Agriculture and a house bill is uh
approved in the lower house and it is
the the the Senate now is uh creating a
a joint a camera committee on this
talking on this and and uh actually the
first thing that they are doing is to
include this in the curriculum
because
it is the youth that needs this to to be
to learn these things so this is going
to be reaching down into like Elementary
School High School yes sir yes sir
because from uh the elementary school
the lab of filling the soil or growing
food like this must be thought
yes ma'am
your lives
oh we have in the Philippines the
international rights Research Institute
and we also have a Philippine version of
that which we call the Philippine rice
Institute of the field rats which try to
improve our our varieties
and before let's say 20 years ago our
the average uh
uh Harvest of rice per hectare is only
about 75 kavans this is about 50
kilograms in one you know sack like that
but today our Farmers know because of
the influence of these two institutes
they and the the Improvement of the uh
varieties we are now growing about 200
kabans per hectare
of course
the land area is reduced
because of you know as we grow the
population and also the the urban
uh because of the industries they are
you uh we are losing several hectares of
land every year
but with that uh increase in Harvest
because of the Improvement of rice
varieties
we have
and also the only problem that we have
there is the climate
no matter how how uh good our productive
systems here we do not have full control
of the
somehow they are trying to to improve
the varieties having this uh resistance
to weed resistance to to
uh drought and submergence to water
chat uh let's take this one first time
part like
types stuff like that
um so have there been any challenges
on certain structure or post a bunch of
the same Enterprise oh
uh using this uh low-tech technology we
have somehow improved the production
and there are several studies on
uh comparing this in the the traditional
system
we have improved the production
because you can do this everywhere
even in the uh cities I just don't know
whether I answered your program
and um
the intervention of the city government
is really very great
because there in the city especially in
Metro Manila they are employing this
this uh uh incentive that if you in
terms of vacant lot in an area or let's
say in a subdivision you can utilize
them and the owner of that lab
will be Exempted to to taxes
and so a lot of people in the community
utilize those uh technique and the owner
of those uh lands actually or those Lads
are actually
uh like the the idea rather than keeping
it very dirty and uh you know weeds will
grow there and it's very
um
not nice to look at especially the city
there's a question that came in on the
zoo oh
uh Paul writes hello thank you for
sharing your experience could you please
let me know how to how to split the cost
of hydroponic equipment the participant
pay for the equipment who manages the
technical stuff such as the nutrient
solution and then do you teach them how
to manage the crops okay right so
there's there's the expenses involved
yes uh in the Philippines you know the
the investors are really afraid to
invest because you know
so we have to cut the cost to cut the
cost of our establishment that's why we
utilize everything what is there in the
locality especially the uh substrate
here you use uh different types
Brown pool the
expanded claim
and we are going to import that in the
Philippines
so we use what is locally available like
gravel like uh volcanic Cinder like
lahar
we have a lot of Lahar in the
Philippines because of the Pinatubo
eruption you remember that one and
because we are rice producing country we
utilize rice hub
and carbonized rice hot and we are also
having this uh waste of coconut uh you
know from the coconut
so we have a lot of cocoa choir and
cocoa uh beet to use rather than
importing them now for the cost of
establishment of greenhouse we try to
simplify the greenhouse
but thinking into consideration the
impact of Thai foods that we have
so far
our design is good enough to withstand
the signal number three that you have
about
less than 200 kilometers per hour wind
so we can still manage to get that one
so
what we have there is we usually share
what we know
everything
just to help
our farmers and from the establishment
of the greenhouse on how to prepare the
seeds
even to Growing the maintenance of the
nutrient solution uh we do that in
seminars
now uh in fact there are so many
available materials that was recorded
by our the Department of Agriculture and
the department of Science and Technology
available online for them
you just click uh see LSU
Chito
Google
is there and it is available
I also have some Publications
for some of these Technologies which are
available free online
so that is how we could help and we have
our team in central Arizona State
University that when you request
from our University president
we can send even in the farthest place
in the Philippines just to help
extend what we have known and shared to
them whatever they need
all right beginning of your presentation
uh has that affected your efforts at all
yes of course
you know you know this sounds funny but
you know I just uh years ago we are
about number three in Asia about
corruption
two or three years later we are number
one and it is this is what is happening
one of these people in in uh that those
countries tell that
corruption in their country is always
done under the table
and
another country oh
that's nothing corruption in our country
happens oh on top of the table
but in the Philippines it's different
we include the table in the Philippines
that is how bad I hope it would be
corrected actually we are
just laughing at this but you know
production is everywhere
but probably worse in our country
yes sir I'm curious if there's uh
vegetables like uh native to the
Philippines or the population uses that
we're not maybe aware of in the U.S but
you're finding like success growing them
in the Philippines yes sir we can do uh
some research about that but
introducing some of ours that is how
that is why some of our University my
friends there wanted to make
collaboration with
Cornell
we really love to learn from you
we really need
more knowledge how to improve our
systems
yes sir how much
um
or we usually uh do what we call
Tropical Greenhouse
tropical means whatever the surroundings
you will utilize that yes
so we I usually discourage them to
introduce funds they call them
and what we have is only a motor
and
a system we call passive system just to
pull the nutrient solution
we do not use any cooling systems
and just to limit the cost of energy and
the investment uh
so we call it we tropicalize the system
of course it is the growth is affected
but somehow we can grow
number one there is the presence the
devastation of insects
so inside the greenhouse of course we
will not spray
especially for short duration crops like
living vegetables
we try to limit the interest
oh yeah uh so far our structure uh it is
just made of uh
iron pipes
and it is fully welded
and
uh
strongly connected to the ground
so and we do some bracing
just not to allow water during typhoons
heavy downfall to to go inside and
affect our crops and of course the
strong wind
somehow we were we were successful in
doing those uh structures
so they were good through category three
yes it is about not it is about uh 200
kilometers per hour something like that
very strong if you have if you uh know a
coconut tree
it would bend to about
50 to 45 degrees like that in Signal
number
you can see a bamboo then put
Bend like that signal
and we somehow uh managed to
have those structures
all right uh let's hold the stop
questions there and thank uh
thank you very much
and of course to my host professor
and also to Cornell and to all of you
thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu